- So before we go to break,
it's the first day of Black History Month
and you have a special connection
to the civil rights movement, right?
- Yes, absolutely.
- This is awesome, what is it?
- My grandfather, Reverend Hosea Williams,
the late Reverend Hosea Williams,
he worked, there's a picture right there
with Dr. Martin Luther King.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Wow.
- He was his right-hand man.
He used to call my grandfather
the bull in the China cabinet
because he was the one when
they went to go marching,
he would get everybody rallied up.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes.
And energized and ready for the march,
and the purpose of the march.
And so my grandfather's legacy
is that he was a civil rights activist
and my family still
runs our family charity,
it's called 4hosea.
- That's so cool.
- [Porsha Williams] Yeah.
- That's an amazing connection.
- Like especially around
- Absolutely.
this time like reminded
every year what your family,
those are amazing footprints
to leave behind.
- Absolutely,
and you know Black History Month
is a month for us to really celebrate
who we are and our ancestors before us.
So being able to educate the youth
and myself even more about
so many positive black people
who have been gone before
us and their footprints,
we are now walking in is
such a powerful thing to do.
- And even if you're not black,
it's an amazing time for everybody
to learn about something
maybe you didn't know.
- And highlight the black experience.
So black businesses, et cetera.
Just lets everybody be black this month.